continuing on with how Shauna is
processing everything one of my favorite
lines I think it comes up in episode
three is when she's got the gun and she
says my hand isn't shaking because I'm
afraid it's because I want to do this so
badly how how do you define her
bloodlust is it bloodlust because she
has a drive to kill or is it something
that's specifically triggered by the
need to protect I don't know if it I
think it's a it's a
tricky it feels almost a bit like trying
to psychoanalyze myself
um I honestly wonder if part of it is
there's so much that she's not feeling
there's so much that she's not dealing
with and things that she's trying to
forget and so she lives in a kind of
extended state of numbness for a lot of
her life where she's just pushing things
away and that's an easy way to get
adrenaline and to feel something and to
be like oh wait I am a human being by
doing something absolutely insane and
she remembers oh I like that I like that
feeling and she's always like that
feeling even before she crashes in the
wilderness there is something like a
little bit wrong with her that made her
seek that feeling out so I think now
she's just sort of like
trying to figure out how much she can
just get that feeling back without
killing another person or doing
something absolutely crazy
um
but also over the course of the Season
you know you can push things down
forever they're gonna come out speaking
of that they do come out at the police
station and I I feel like that might be
one of the most truthful beats for the
character than we've seen the entire
season so when you're playing a moment
like that what justifies that happening
then for you why that particular moment
and why expose all of that truth to a
complete stranger that's a really good
question such a strange thing to do I
just feel like
she works so hard to stop herself from
doing things that then things just
happen she's just operating from
just adrenaline and fear and panic and
she just she doesn't even I feel like
it's like she blacks out kind of
for me personally like I'm a John
Reynolds Super Fan so I wanted to sing
with him I was like I just want to sing
with them I just want to do anything so
even though I was like this is insane
what she's doing in the scene I wasn't
gonna ask any questions in case someone
took the scene away because it's with
John Reynolds and I just love him so
much I don't blame you oh my God it was
so fun it's like endlessly fascinating
analyzing these characters Christina a
specific line and more more importantly
a specific reaction shot that I love of
yours is after Elijah says the line
maybe I'm just a board Moriarty looking
for his Sherlock because they give you a
really nice long reaction shot where the
entire time we see the wheels in your
head turning can you kind of walk us
through what it's like reacting to
something like that and have her make a
decision where she's not voicing the
decision she's making well that uh
uh that part is is fine I I love when I
get to just do things with my face and
not have to say stuff
um but I but we did I haven't seen that
episode and we did not different
versions of that take so I'm not sure
which one they used I thought it was
great what were the two most polar
opposite uh creative choices you made
while playing that scene well we were
playing with you know playing with this
idea that you know if she's a character
that's never had anybody really be that
interested in her and most people know
to run away and to shun her and all of
this stuff how would this person react
to all of a sudden somebody wanting
somebody pursuing her
um and I very much felt like she would
just think there was something wrong
with that person
um which I feel like is is a lot of how
it's played
um for for many of the episodes
um and then I think you know
I
kind of always want
for her to be
fight you know fighting her
um
her hopes and fighting what she thinks
would be an amazing outcome because
she's so used to it never being given to
her that I I don't think that she's just
going to be like gung-ho yes this is
amazing
um so I think we did like several
different versions of complicated
feelings it's very very good I can
assure you that Lauren I have a feeling
you probably haven't seen this
particular reaction shot but there was
one moment that I was waiting for of
yours the entire time the point where
they're all at lottie's compound because
like we see Lottie and I I had a sense
of what everyone's reaction to seeing
Lottie at that point was going to be
except for vans so what was it like
figuring out the right reaction for her
to have the first time she laid eyes on
Lottie after all these years oh I don't
know if it was right but uh it was what
I did
um uh
I guess
that
van was a a very early believer and um
early
acolyte into lottie's world in the
wilderness into her belief system and I
think
the adult band as a grown-up she's like
completely skewed that and thought like
that's that's and it's like
that's uh uh something that happened in
a crazy time and I can just put that
away and it wasn't real and being face
to face
with it again is just
shocking and jarring and and something
you know in this character is very much
closed down and that that's like the the
very beginning of something being
cracking open very successful with that
it's mainly focused on your reaction in
simones and it's just like emotion
bursting off of the screen in a way that
made it so hard that that's where our
press screeners cut off I couldn't stand
it I'll end with this question for all
three of you I love focusing on the
value of a good scene partner can you
name a particular moment in the first uh
six episodes of season two where a scene
partner gave you what you needed in
order to access something in your own
character
good question well you're great um
I would say
Elijah was constantly giving me
everything that I needed for the scenes
to work I mean he was just making the
scenes work all the time
um
so yeah I can't pick a single moment
because he just is he he really carried
so much of those scenes so many of those
seats you two are perfect together that
Cadence is just spot on
I think for me like doing like six
scenes and stuff like that is always
awkward and I'm very very grateful to
have Warren like he and I now have such
a trust with each other and there's that
scene and the first episode where we go
on to the art studio and have sex and
like
I'm just so I remember just feeling so
back at work and like oh my god
um and being so grateful that I have
this trust with them and we can really
talk about things and also like
we have like a thing that feels like a
couple and we're very like natural with
each other and he's just he's also very
funny he's always really fun to work
with yeah you two are great yet again
Sarah is crushing it she's amazing
really really good yeah how about for
you Lauren's team partner they really
appreciate it just
I know that in some respects I'm not
meant to talk about it but but I
obviously get to play some amazing
really lovely scenes with Tawny Cyprus
who's a beautiful actor and
um just I mean she's just a great person
to work with and
um the ability to play and and be light
and fun and both on set and in the
scenes and
um I don't know I think it was just very
supportive and I'm really grateful for
her work and my one regret on this show
is that I don't get to do scenes with
Liv I wish that I could
um I you know I'm such I'm such an
admirer of their work and I I um obvious
reasons and I that's the one the one
person I wish I could work with